welcome
back for those of you who've been here
before welcome to the next installment
of this
series at the whitney humanities center
at yale called the value of marx's
capital
a little bit tongue-in-cheek but
we're trying to think about the new
values that
can be produced by reading it
differently and reading it today
with some of the most interesting
interpreters of the
text of the moment these are the frankie
lectures in the humanities
the series is a companion to an
undergraduate seminar at yale
can you all just give me a thumbs up if
you can hear me
okay good thank you got nervous there
for a minute
um and it also goes along with the work
that my collaborator paul writer at osu
is doing on a new translation of volume
1 into english
which i am co-editing with him that
should be out
we hope in our lifetimes
um i need to thank first of all
the frankie family who make possible the
frankie lectures that's richard and
barbara frankie
these lectures are intended to present
important topics in the humanities to a
wide and general audience
i'd like to thank alice kaplan the
director of the whitney humanities
center who's already
doing brilliant things beginning in her
first term
uh sandra malone bowles who's an
administrator at the whitney who's
organized everything in the on the back
end
lyanna hirschfeld crown who's our
graduate assistant who's organized
everything on the front end
and audrey leake who is our
undergraduate assistant
running the show the technological show
we're going to do what we always do
which is have a presentation
and after that we'll take questions i'm
going to ask you to keep your questions
note them down and then to put them in
the chat after i give the signal and
we'll go through them
one by one as they're relevant to the
talk
don't post your questions now because
they'll get lost
i like to start with a quotation from a
work
by our author and here i'm going to
quote from the introduction to a book
edited
by titi bhattacharya social reproduction
theory in 2017
quote if as we propose the special
separation between production
public and reproduction private
is a historical form of appearance then
the labor that is dispensed in both
spheres must also be
theorized integratively i take this to
be a kind of a motto and a project
that she has been carrying out for many
years
and i'd like to introduce her professor
titi bhattacharya is a professor of
south asian history
and director of global studies at purdue
university
she's the author of the sentinels of
culture class education and the colonial
intellectual in bengal
from 2005 and has been a longtime
activist for palestinian justice
she's a type of person who brings her
intellectual work together with her
work as a social justice activist
in the most admirable way locally
across the world with students so i'm
really very happy that she's
here she's written extensively on marx's
theory
on gender and her work has been
published in the journal of asian
studies
um south asia research and she is one of
the authors
of feminism for the 99 percent along
with
um chincia aruza who's going to be here
at the end of this series and nancy
frazier
i'd like all of us to if we can
virtually applaud and welcome tt
bhattacharya to the series
welcome
thank you paul for that very very
generous
introduction um i also have
a few thank yous before i start um
thank you paul norris and paul reiter
for inviting me to this
a brilliant project of um
sort of discussing a capital volume one
at a moment of real crisis in our world
and discussing it with uh not just
the the general public but also very
crucially
with undergraduates in the university so
thank you
i also want to thank lyanna and audrey
for helping
me with the with the presentation and
thank you to
all of you who are tuning in and i look
forward to
engaging with you on this issue
this is a very um important
seminar series and a very unique one
because i i had the good fortune to
actually
hear my the previous speakers for this
at the seminar and it's unique because
usually when i speak about um
capital volume 1 or marxist theory in
general i had to spend a lot of time
introducing what social reproduction
theory is
in this seminar my colleague and comrade
lucia predella has already introduced
a social reproduction theory before um
before my talk so i'm very grateful that
this
has already been a live category of
engagement and conversation
so um i'm going to start um
with
i'm sorry i there is something
wrong can we put up your slide
presentation are we at that moment
no sorry it's um
it's it it's not um somehow my
file is not opening properly
i'm sorry i apologize
okay it is now okay
so um
capital um for most of you who have
engaged with the text
quite extensively already know
that it is of course about the working
class and hence
it is about labor but this
claim can appear a bit controversial
because
barring a few passages and the very
famous
chapter on the working day capital as a
text
is actually predominantly concerned with
abstract labor
or the value form of labor so
what do i mean about the value form of
labor meaning that the text
talks not so much about work or labor
except that famous chapter but about
labor power the capacity to labor
which is what the worker is forced to
sell to the capitalist
and the text also spends a lot of time
discussing
how that labor power through a rather
torturous
process turns into surplus value or
profit
but since it is capital that best
teaches us
that the value form violates and
extinguishes
all sensuous properties of human labor
marx's central concern in capital
appears to be
tracing the procedures of that
extinguishment
rather than establishing the subjective
conscious
aspects of human labor
this particular reading of capital as a
text
organized solely around the formed
determination of wage labor
has actually led some marxists to make
a further analytical leap about the
indifference
if you like of capitalism as a mode of
production
so for instance ellen mikson good a
prominent
advocate of this view has argued that
audrey could we have the first slide
please thank you
so it's the next slide audrey thank you
so uh ellen wood has argued that sexual
and racial equality
are not in principle incompatible with
capitalism
the disappearance of class inequality on
the other hand
is by definition incompatible with
capitalism
so in other words you know we can
have a capitalism where
there is no sexual or racial inequal uh
inequality
but we can't have a capitalism where
there's class
equality in this reading of marx
capitalism as a system
is reconstructed as the first and only
exploitative system that does not
require the production and sustenance
of extra economic inequalities
the existence of such inequalities is
seen as contingent
rather than exigent to the system whose
reproduction can be assured simply
through the wage form
or through the extraction of surplus
value between
economically unequal but juridically
equal subjects
social reproduction theory a conceptual
apparatus primarily developed from
capital by marx's feminists
i will argue today offers a reading of
capitalism and of capital volume 1 that
is actually
more consistent with marx's own method
than this hypothesis
of capitalist indifference next slide
please
so i make this argument in three
separate
but related ways first at a general
level by looking at the status of labor
in capital
uh second through a more specific
argument about capitalism systemic unity
and this sort of harkens back to the
the code that uh paul um
used from uh my my essay earlier
and so and finally through an empirical
argument about
how it is exactly that labor power is
differentiated dividing the working
class into distinct sectors
so let me preface my argument with some
very brief remarks
about social reproduction theory or srt
and its theoretical contours
fundamentally srt theorizes labor power
and the practices that enable its
reproduction within
capitalist social relations situated
within and following from the
conceptual architecture of capital
srt proposes that next slide please
one the labor expended
in the production of commodities that is
at the point of production
and the labor expended for the
production of people
or workers who produce such commodities
are
part of the same capitalist totality
and together constitutive of value
and the second proposal is that the
working class family is the primary
but not the only site for the
reproduction of labor power
or the reproduction of the working class
as a whole
srt identifies capital's contradictory
relationship to labor power
as a key feature of the system how is it
contradictory
because on the one hand capital needs a
steady predictable circuit for the
reproduction of labor power
since it is the source of capital's
profit and hence its
own reproduction so it has to have
reliable means
that labor power is reproduced
constantly
but on the other hand that labor power
is actually reproduced by human beings
and hence how it is reproduced to what
extent
labor power's capacities are developed
or the human capacities are developed
may not always align with capital's
needs
thus all sites and processes
for the reproduction of labor power are
ultimately
arenas of contestation between labor and
capital
the former constantly tending towards
greater share of civilization
to develop and further human capacities
so that's labor's job while the latter
i.e capital straining to reduce such a
share
and mold labor power and such capacities
to create and maintain the productive
worker
that capital needs so
let's let's look at some examples right
so think about
what kind of a worker
uh capitalism needs and how do we attain
it
so in that sense you know you
have um you know great discipline
at schools to produce the perfect
you know subject for work
later on in life you have
you know the heteronormative family as
the ideal that capital is most
comfortable with
in order to reproduce labor power so you
have all these institutions
but then these institutions
do not always work as reliably as
possible because look
we're at yale and we're teaching capital
volume one
i.e we are encouraging you to actually
think about the system rather than
comply with the system
so there's always the this sort of
contradictory relationship
between the processes of the production
of commodities
and the processes of the production of
labor power
so slide five please and
we can see that this contestation
happens i i'm not sure if you can see uh
both of the photographs very well that
this contestation then can happen
both at the point of production and
outside of it the first
photo is of um
homeowners in chicago actually um
protesting redlining and the second is a
point of production
um you know obviously a worker strike
at at woolworths and we'll we'll talk
about this
more later so srt
then is at its core concerned with the
gendered
racialized reproduction of labor power
and capital as text is
fundamentally concerned with how
surplus value is produced and with what
consequences
then how are the two related so
positions such as ellen woods above
that we talked about try to demonstrate
that capitalist social relations
as they unfold historically ought to be
theoretically separated out from the
abstract or logical architecture of
capitalism
so in this view you can have a historic
capitalism
which is how it really happens but
capital volume one it can be argued is
actually
the abstraction and and is not really
about history or or anything
so this particular derivation
of capital um and approach to capitalism
are in my
view actually at odds with both marx's
methodology
and the project of cavity
capital volume one is individually about
the value form of labor and we can
certainly find passages and marks which
might support the argument that economic
categories ought to be considered
distinctly from their historic unfolding
however we cannot lose sight of the fact
that what distinguishes marx's method
from
non-marxist ones say ricardo's concept
of fixed essences
is that marx rejects a separation
between reality
and its apprehension in thought instead
his methodology establishes a
dialectical
unity between them operating
simultaneously at both logical
and historical levels to be clear
marx is um not proposing a simple unity
between theory and reality
in any naturalistic way but of how
theoretical categories
actually derive from historic
developments
this does not mean that such categories
are reflective
of immediate appearances indeed
as we know from our reading of marx they
may be their mirror
opposites rather his method discloses
a constant upward spiral movement
between theory and reality or appearance
and essence
however you want to think about it
becoming more complex at each successive
level of determination
so this relationship between
capital volume one is a theoretical text
and
history or reality existing outside of
the text
is often cast as a relationship between
abstract categories
and concrete histories right so so far
we've argued that there is a
relationship between the abstract
categories and concrete history
but actually marx goes much further than
this simple relationality
so what is an abstract category let's
try to unpack that a bit
an abstract category commonly understood
is a static one
right one that doesn't move doesn't
change with historical
change and so on an unmoving part
separated from a dynamic hole which can
reveal to the analyst
key features of that hole because that
whole is impossible to study in in its
totality or
complete complexity marx himself uses
several such abstractions
money commodity being you know two
two of the most common ones to
understand history and the nature of
capitalism
but unlike bourgeois approaches to
abstraction
marx's methodology refuses all static
forms hence one of the you know
uh key theorists according to me
of uh marx's uh method
which is uh bertil omen uh vertil ullman
has
argued that marx sets out to abstract
things in his words as they really are
and happen making how they happen
part of what they are hence capital
or labor or money is not only
how capital appears and functions but
also how it develops or rather how it
develops
its real history is also part of what it
is
so um just to sort of
do an aside here if if um
if you remember uh in in the german
ideology
he and engels mock bruno bauer for
attempting to prove
an antithetical relationship between
nature and history
as if and marx says and i quote these
were
two separate things unquote
in contrast a marxist abstraction so
this sort of category that you abstract
from the whole to understand the whole
a marxist abstraction encloses within it
both a history of its becoming while
disclosing
its possible future for instance
within the abstract category capital
we also find its past which is
the so-called primitive accumulation as
well as
forecasts of its future constant
expansion through surplus value
extraction the accumulation drive
creating the world market and so on so
the past
as well as the future is enclosed
in the abstract category of of capital
so while we might find these categories
in whole or in part in
other epochs of history i.e in other
modes of production like we will find
money or
you know labor and so on they either
remain
unrealized in their function or play
entirely different roles from their
current incarnation
what they combine when they combine in
the
capitalist mode of production they do so
as being simultaneously
saturated with their past while
establishing
new relationships within themselves so
the
history of pre-capitalist practices
thus cannot be separated or severed
from the explanatory categories of
capitalism
so this is a digression in sort of
abstract how the methodology that i
think
is is useful in going back to reading
capital and once
you know we have this methodology in
place let us now revisit
ellen wood's claim that the extraction
of
value is the primary concern for capital
and hence
how that process happens
i.e whether that process happens to
racialize
gendered or ableist means is actually
incidental to capital central pursuit
right
so remember we are now talking so if we
use that
idea then
marx's methodology doesn't really apply
because as we try to establish that the
abstract in marx
actually discloses the history of the
category
itself and discloses its unfolding
so e as we've already then established
that even
abstract categories and marks carry
historical lineages
and futural illusions in a sense
this should be enough to reject wood's
claim of capitalist
indifference but there is actually a
case
to be made for indifference as regards
to capitalist forms
not however in the way that ellen wood
conceives of it
so let us take the abstract category
labor
as it appears in marx it is just binary
true
that human beings have always labored in
a diversity of historical epochs and
social formations
but labor as a simple category that marx
uses to build the theoretical
infrastructure of capital volume one
when economically conceived in this
simplicity says marx
it becomes and i quote
a modern category as the relations which
create this simple abstraction
so capital so under capitalism labor
as such not any specific kind of labor
not the uh you know sort of act of you
know building a table
or teaching or cooking not any specific
kind of labor
but labor as such becomes the basis for
the creation of wealth
to conceive of labor in this its most
simple form
was an analytical leap taken by
classical political economy
which actually marks is very uh much
in support of and and you know
absolutely um
uh gives props to adam smith uh
he's he wrote it was a tremendous
advance on the part of adam smith
um to throw aside every limiting
specification of wealth creating
activity
not only manufacturing or commercial or
agricultural labor
but one as well as the others labor
in general so you know the smith
first came upon this um idea and
and marx follows very much from it
but how did classical political economy
arrive
at this generalized form of labor
not simply because laboring wasn't a
historical category common to all epochs
but because labor under capitalism had
become for the first time
labor in general so the theoretical
conception of this general or
simple form of labor was only possible
in the historical actuality
of very developed totality of real kinds
of labor
of which no single one was any longer
predominant
unquote as marx put it so abstraction
in this case the abstract category of
labor
arose from the very many determinations
of the concrete
while the concrete could only be
conceived off
as such through the simple abstraction
so it is only when the system itself the
historical system itself was indifferent
to what kind of labor remember the first
like five chapters of capital volume one
right so all of you've gone through it
so um so the most
general abstractions marx reminds us
arise
only in the midst of the richest
possible
concrete development and i quote marx
where one thing appears as common to
many
to all then it ceases to be thinkable
in a particular form alone right so it
was the
historical development and the concrete
unfolding of it that allowed classical
political economists
to have uh to to make that analytical
leap towards abstraction so you can see
here i'm sort of
building this argument that the concrete
and the abstract
actually have a relationship in marks in
the methodology
so now you can see where i will go with
this with whether
uh the creation of surplus value is
indifferent
to how surplus value is produced right
so that's that's
the argument we are leading up to with
all this uh discussion on the abstract
and the concrete
it is because indifference in real sense
is expressed in the historical form
that it can be grasped as such in the
abstract theoretical form
uh it is because individuals in
capitalist society can fluidly move from
one form of labor to another
that both the category labor
and labor in reality has become
and i code marks the means of creating
wealth in general
and has ceased to be organically linked
to particular individuals in
any specific form hence
far from there being an abstract
capitalism
indifferent to historical forms and in
historical capitalism marked by concrete
social relations
marx's methodology urges critical
thought
to unite theory and reality
in actually transformatively radical
ways
right so we don't need to have this
sort of historical capitalism versus
abstract capitalism
we should actually think about marx's
methodology
challenges us to think about uh
rejecting this sort of a division in
thinking but think about a dialectical
unity
at within the categories themselves
so um accordingly marx
posits abstract labor in capital volume
one
and you you are all very aware of this
very carefully
and he posits it as one aspect
of his labor theory of value subjective
forms are concrete labor
the analytical twin of abstract labor
and social labor through which the value
form is organized
are all understood as different aspects
of
labor operating as in unity right
so most importantly
capital volume one is about why
and how abstract labor
dominates over the other aspects
and submits them to the law of value
right so that's
really but it doesn't mean that there is
an abstract labor that we study about
and then there is concrete labor it
actually shows you
why abstract labor dominates over
concrete labor
if the um other aspects of labor
like concrete labor and social labor
appear
as muted shadows of abstract labor
then it is not because marx is reporting
on reality in any simple way
these other categories in capital have a
much more significant role to play
in the totality of marx's argument
concrete labor or social labor actually
these theoretical categories actually
signal
the limits to capitalism's ability
to reduce workers to simply being
potential sources
of surplus value okay so we should think
about these categories
not simply as explaining how surplus
value is created
but also these categories signal the
limits
to what capital can extract from us
so let us look more closely then at the
relationship between
abstract and concrete labor and their
respective roles in capitalism
a system organized on the basis of or
abstract labor
as we argued before can only appear when
different forms of concrete labor
performed by historically situated
people
are forced into a relationship of
equivalence
via the market production for which
takes place solely for profit
rather than for human need so the system
reproduces itself through the production
of commodities
a process involving abstract labor
or labor in its value form but
constantly
rubbing against this process while
nested within it
human beings reproduce their lives
through concrete
historically laden actions reproduction
of life-making practices
and the reproduction of value must be
simultaneous
and continuous okay which is
the reality of capitalism but also a
sense of anxiety for capital right
because it does not have the kind of
control it has
at the point of production over the
production of commodities
it doesn't have the same control over
the production of life-making
or reproduction of life-making if you
like because it doesn't happen at the
point of production
so slide six please um
two preconditions attend to such a
system
that is capitalism one that
people are forcibly torn from the means
of production
such that access to their subsistence or
life making
is only available through the mechanism
of the market
and second if the system is able to
ensure its continued reproduction
by reproducing the social relations that
scaffold the market
and the extraction of surplus value in
other words
capitalist social relations must
continually reproduce
the workers dependence on capital so
both things as you can see here in this
wonderful feminist graphic from the
1970s
both things are happening at the same
time the woman is split
down in the middle um to to my left
she is um you know performing
labor in in the uh domestic sphere
um many of you listening in
can identify with that especially during
pandemic times
of your children at home and
pulling at your skirt and on the right
on my right she is also working in the
workplace
and you can see i always find
this very interesting because there is a
there's a clock
that that marks time in in the workplace
so
so it's a it's a wonderful image that
shows
uh you know both sides of capital how
capital reproduces itself as as a system
so the dominance of abstract over
concrete labor
of value over use value create the
conditions
for and necessitate the production of a
worker
compliant to capitals every whim okay
because
if there isn't a compliant worker then
there would be no system
so that's that's capitals need right but
if this were the whole story of capitals
vol 1 then celebration of its 150th
birthday would be held at wall street
but how if at all is then resistance
part of this story
if marx's theory requires all parts of a
social
totality to be connected through
internal relations
how can resistance to capital be shown
to be
imminent to the reproduction of capital
right because
resistance can't be from the outside it
can't be an external relation that's
that's going against marxist methodology
and this is where to go back to our
point
social reproduction theory deploying
capital smith
methodology but building upon some of
its silences
affects a category transformation of the
concept of labor power
as the analytical causeway the
analytical bridge
between capitalist reproduction and
anti-capitalist resistance
so even the most
creative reading of the concept of labor
power and capital
shows and this is you know the feminists
big fight
with capital volume one that the text
presupposes the existence of what is
being reproduced
so labor power is just there in capital
volume one
theoretically it's a category that's
just there
discussion of labor power begins not
from where
or how it has been societally produced
but the ways in which in its commodity
form
it sustains the production of surplus
value
differently put conceptualization of
labor power in the text
is limited to the form in which it is
useful to capital
srt agitates this capital-oriented view
of labor power
and performs in theory a reverse
movement
away from the site of commodity
production to the site
of the reproduction of labor power
so labor power for those of you who've
read the text
um i'm talking about the students and
in the seminar um you know that it is
nominated variously in capital as
unique special peculiar commodity
because it is presented as the only
commodity and in marx's famous words
whose used value possesses the peculiar
property of being
a source of value and i'm so excited to
to see how um paul reiser and paul nurse
will will translate that that passage
i'm really excited to learn from that
but srt reveals that there is another
aspect to labor power's peculiarity
it is a commodity undoubtedly but it is
a commodity that is
not produced capitalistically that is
within the
direct ambit of the capital wage
relation
labor relation right so it's produced
outside of it
uh you know uh the the the feminist who
pioneered some of this
thinking lisa vogel has shown that it is
produced and reproduced what
lisa lisa vogel calls a kin-based
site which is the working class family
so this insight is is crucial
and it is crucial in three important
respects
first because it expresses the
dialectical unity
of what we had argued previously between
the historical and logical form of
capital
right labor power srt shows can
only become available to capital through
distinct
but reliable sets of gendered racialized
social relations that create their
own institutional forms of sustenance
such as
the monogamous heteronormative family
form
older historical forums may be recast
new forms may be created and mobilized
but it is
only through concrete social relations
and
census human labor that labor power is
produced and made
available to capital second
being attentive to labor power not as it
appears before capital
but as it is produced and reproduced
srt introduces or rather restores
to capitalist totality a sphere of
social relations
where life-making activities proliferate
while capital's goal is to increase
surplus value in the sphere of
production
the worker's goal is to enhance her
quality of life
or a qualitative enrichment of her labor
power and her selfhood
through the satisfaction of her needs
srt reminds us
of the power of these life-making
activities by workers
for they seek to impose breaks on the
process of accumulation
as capital is forced to pay for them
through wages and social benefits
so look at let's go back and look at
this picture
right so look look at the
what is to my left side of of the of the
graphic which is one way
that uh th this
uh woman worker could enhance the
quality of the left side of her
uh of her work sphere is
by having public child care these
these um the the crying child on the
floor
would actually be at a public
well-funded government child care
institution
and you can see um that she's ironing so
we could have public laundries
and so on and so if on the right side
of the graphic she went on strike to
demand that
then that is actually again putting a
break on the accumulation
process for her to enhance the quality
of her life so you see there is a
relationship between the production of
commodity
and the reproduction of labor power
so finally there is a clear strategic
component
to srt life life-making social practices
by workers are not
simply conjuries of activities to
satisfy
needs they have the potential to carry
an anti-capitalist charge struggles to
enhance or
expand such practices will always reveal
the balance of class forces
that i want better public health care in
fact
i want my health care to be free i want
education to be free
this is not to claim that any or all
struggles by workers to improve their
little
living conditions are all anti-systemic
struggles
um but it is to argue
that um uh that that they
carry that at the potential for
that sort of um uh anti-capitalist
charge um
the the struggles that are about
enhancing the sphere of life making for
workers can thus reveal
often implicitly but sometimes
explicitly
the upper limits to what the working
class can claim
in its goal for self-enhancement and
liberation
thus they carry the potential of
teaching the worker in struggle
the most important political lesson
about capitalism
that while the wage forces life-making
activities can never be free of
the drive for accumulation and thus real
emancipation
life and labor is only possible with the
abolition of the wage form
right so we can demand for instance
that we have free abortion on demand
we have free medical care or free
education
and in certain contexts capital will
even grant that
but immediately try to claw it back when
it can right so again this sort of
struggle to constantly win
back from capital our life making
activities or our potential
for expanded life making activities is a
continuous process
and it'll never end till the abolition
of the wage form itself
so if srt establishes
the non-capitalistic production of labor
power
and its reproduction through particular
gendered and racialized social relations
it also raises more troubling questions
about the procedures of its reproduction
the production of value and the
extraction of surplus value as
demonstrated in capital have certain
tendencies and counter tendencies that
seek equalization throughout the system
but the hallmark of capitalism surely is
its
deep social inequality both between the
capitalist
class and workers and within the classes
themselves
so the production of surplus value
unpacks the secret of inequalities
between capital and labor
but what explains the sustenance of
inequality
amongst workers right what explains
the wage gap what explains the
racialized wage gap
so traditional marxist accounts of
racism within the working class for
example
locate the production and reproduction
of race in labor market competition
the argument goes that workers compete
with each other as individual
sellers of labor power on the market and
historically dominant sections of the
class
compete with the more vulnerable
sections of the class
over jobs pensions and social benefits
right so
all of the racism is then reproduced or
produced
in the first place within the labor
market itself right for competing jobs
and so on
so i agree with the broad outlines of
this account but i think
srt urges us to push the question
of differentiation further and
pitch it not just at the level of the
labor market
but at the level of production of the
value of labor power
okay so the labor market is about the
price of labor power
but we want to situate the question at
the level of production of the value of
labor power
okay so the value of labor power as a
commodity we all know and this is again
your first five
chapters of capital volume one uh like
all commodities under capitalism the
value of labor power is determined by
the value of the means of subsist
subsistence that is needed for its
reproduction
so next slide please
so this is your um
sorry audrey the next slide please oh
there we go thank you
um so um the
um you know and and there are actually
it is actually almost institutionally
recognized sometimes because that's what
the federal minimum wage is
right forget the fact that it's been
stuck there
but um but you know the the wage basket
as it were
is your means of subsistence that
creates
um uh the the labor power okay
but marx reminds us that for this
peculiar commodity labor power
and and in contra distinction from all
the other kind of commodities under
capitalism
there enters what marx calls quote
unquote
a historical and moral element
in the determination of its value now
what the hell does that mean
because he says that there may be
okay i just thought i am
sorry that's okay
um so what is the historical and moral
element
so this marx introduces this concept
to to say this that there might be a
lower limit
to what the laboring body needs to
reproduce itself
right so there is only you can only
like be hungry to a certain level or
thirsty to a certain level
after which the human body will die so
there can be a lower limit
to what the body needs to go to work the
next day
okay but
there can be no fixed upper limit to the
workers necessary needs
as needs themselves are dynamic
historically produced
and shaped by the gains made by the
working class through struggle
so a worker in the 1930s
in bangladesh well not in bangladesh at
the time
india it has to be a worker in 1930s
in british india will have very
different needs from the worker
in 2020 in india or bangladesh
or the worker in the u.s today
right so so because those what we
think we absolutely need to go
to work the next day what reproduces our
labor power
it varies between countries between
times and so what marx calls is is a
dynamic process
so um the number and extent of the
workers necessary
once thus marx confirms are themselves
the product of historical development
right so uh let's go to
to slide eight so neces so we can see
in in the in the next slide
you know some of the things that um
that the that the worker uh sorry that
we have come to accept
as sorry the next slide please
so necessary once we have we've come to
accept as something that exists and i
want to talk about the the
two figures here the correction and law
enforcement in a little bit
but this we we take for granted as some
of the things
today that we take for granted as
necessary wants
that we have to uh to reproduce
um as uh the the workers
so if necessary ones which determine the
value of labor power are historical and
dynamic
it follows then that different sections
of the working class
produced at different moments of history
will have different standards of
necessary ones right
the work irish worker for mocks in
direct contrast
with her english counterpart embodied
this
this production of difference for mark
said that the
irish worker was and i quote at that
level of wage labor who accepted
the most animal minimum of needs and
subsistence
in her exchange with capital unquote
okay so the irish worker
uh accepted much uh
a much higher degree of exploitation
than the english worker
according to mark so this version of
productive difference then
situates difference in the very
operation of labor powers reproduction
which means that labor power have
already been differentiated
reproduced even before it reaches the
field of labor market competition
indeed even the access or entry into
labor market cannot be a presupposition
as such access and entry across
different sections of the class
uh precisely uh exists precisely due to
differential
reproduction so now let's go back to
um to the correction and the and the
police
uh law enforcement actually these two
categories
in any working class community has a
very differential effect
on black workers latino workers than it
has uh
than they have on on white workers okay
the kind of disciplining
uh categories that exist have very
different
kind of expectations and
notion of necessary wants than between
black and white workers or latino
workers
so attention to social reproductive
activities then revealed the specific
social processes through which certain
workers
embody certain qualities of labor power
arrive at the doorstep of capital more
vulnerable
and degraded than others ruthlessly
depressed levels of necessary
ones for latino workers in the us is one
example of
brutally differentiated processes of
social reproduction between migrant
workers
and their citizen counterparts the
median
space per person in a latino household
in the us
is 350 square feet
80 square feet less than the
than that of the average non-migrant
family
living below the poverty line okay so
in a similar vein uh we i
i don't need to go through all of this
but if you if you look
at how covet 19
has affected
black uh working-class communities and
latino working-class communities
compared to
white working-class communities it is
very clear
that previous processes of social
differentiation
redlining environmental racism had
already made these communities far more
vulnerable
so when the disease finally hit it
obviously had a differential response in
these communities
as well as you know not just not just
those kind of uh
redlining and environmental racism but
where you know
factories producing uh um
environmentally
um degrading products were are
cited far more frequently in black
communities than they are in non-black
communities right so this has been
established the new york times have
actually done
uh pretty decent reporting uh on on
redlining and industrial waste in in
recent times
so uh we we are looking
at then the the the factor
that certain communities are
historically reproduced
to be more vulnerable even before they
hit the labor market okay
so the idea that the differentiation
happens in the labor market
then we we need to sort of revise and
look at these veins of social
reproduction that exists
before the worker gets to the door
off of the labor market so access to
housing
police violence substandard schools and
healthcare
are obvious ingredients that determine
the level of necessary wants for a
section of the working class
and thereby determine and lower the
value of their labor power
but the lowering of value for one
section of workers always has a
conditioning impulse for all sections
for lower wages for some workers can
allow capital to rationalize and lower
wages for all workers
so degraded social reproduction of
racialized workers thus can help
establish
a regime of cheapened wages for all
so i want to conclude by circling back
to the morphology of labor power
as within it is fused the argument
offered in capital and the significance
of srt
so while it is true that capitalism
tries to produce the working class
it needs capital volume one
shows us that workers struggle against
the wage form is a
necessary part of the internal dynamics
of the system
and its reproduction the worker will
always
tend towards the development of her own
needs through life-making activities
while capital will continually tend
towards
limiting such activities to increase its
share of surplus value
and hence civilization collective
organizing
on the basis of solidarity remains the
only way the working class
can win this unequally resourced battle
against capital the warning we receive
from
srt however is that a multi-racial
working-class unity will not
arise spontaneously through
either left-wing propaganda or
volunteerism
for the differentiation of the working
class is produced and sustained
at a cellular level of the system it is
clear that vicious border policies
gendered and racialized labor regimes
are only
some of the ways in which uh capitalism
seeks to globally reproduce the working
class
in combined but deeply unequal ways
against this warning the aspiration we
receive from srt
is equally important as a unitary theory
revealing the relationship between point
of production of commodities
and the spaces of reproduction of labor
power srt
imbues every struggle for enhanced
social reproduction
with anti-capitalist possibilities a
working class
movement that will be able to give form
to such
possibilities cannot simply retrace
older cultures of solidarity but it will
have to actively forge new ones
such a movement must champion with equal
vigor
working class struggles based in
communities
around water around police violence
around housing
alongside workplace struggles it will
have to learn to articulate demands on a
double register
simultaneously appealing to the
universal and the specific
we should simultaneously demand
universal health care
but make specific demands for access to
reproductive care for better healthcare
for black people
and and so forth there shouldn't be
these should not be understood
as two counterpose strategies but as two
moments in a single necessary process
next slide please so if capital volume 1
remains one of the most savage critiques
of capitalism as a system
srt or social reproduction theory can
perhaps be thought of as animating that
critique
with embodied voices of workers and
struggle
thank you
thank you very much this is the hole
that we fall into at the end of every
talk where there would be thunderous
applause
i know that there's that's happening and
that there's also
um feelings of a possible
new solidarity so thank you for the talk
i want to kick off with a question and
then we can start asking
folks if they want to put questions in
the chat
and we will take them in order
okay i want to ask you this question um
so i've thought for a long time that the
division of labor
is one of the fundamental motors of
capital volume one and of capital as
marx sees it that's not just a static
thing or an
advantage to capital that labor be
divided but it's a kind of dynamic motor
which it keeps getting divided and
redivided
to the for the um
[Music]
the purpose of increasing the
accumulation
and i really like that um the
reproductive space
is brought into this by srt was always
there
but it's brought into this as an effect
of
the division of labor part of the
division of labor almost as though
there's a continuum
and that the the production floor is
right next to the reproduction floor
and these forces are working on both of
them
i guess i want to ask if um
[Music]
if you see them still as or if you see
them as qualitatively different
these two moments
if we we should consider them both labor
in the same way if putting them on a
continuum makes a stronger
possibility for solidarity and if there
have been examples
in history where let's say the domestic
sphere and the production sphere have
gone out on strike together you showed
two images
and the woman has split in half but are
there
are there examples that you know of
where the solidarity has happened
great question paul so um so first of
all
you know the the division
is is um in a sense
when we're talking about it we're
talking about it
it's to to um
to make it easy to analyze right so the
division is a theoretical division but
in reality
you know that the processes um happen
has to happen simultaneously right so i
it's a conceptual division that we've
created
in order to understand the process so
um let me start by saying how it's
different rather than how it's same
because i think we've talked about
you know how it's simultaneous and how
it's seen so
let's think about the difference so
first of all you know
domestic labor while completely
the precondition if you like
to wage labor right so if there was no
domestic labor there would be no wage
labor so while it's a
precondition to wage labor however
domestic labor does not produce value
so we could not have equalized uh
time for diaper change across all
household units of a social
formation you know and thereby
you know produce value from from it so
it doesn't produce value in that sense
even though it is actually the
precondition to the production of value
so that's that's one for sure we cannot
have equalization across
units so we cannot have abstract labor
in the domestic theory it has to be
by necessity concrete labor right so
so that's that's one and the the second
thing
is that i have said that capital
does not have full control over
this this sphere but um
you know often when i've talked about it
this way it may be misunderstood
sometimes by saying that it lies outside
of the
circuit of value production well it
doesn't so what i
mean is it doesn't fall within the
direct control of capital doesn't mean
it lies outside of the circuit
a very simple example would be
um you working in your garden or
one working in their garden
is a non-value producing work it's a
life making activity
it's a concrete labor it's a beautiful
thing
however you can only work in your garden
when your wage labor schedule
allows you to so you can't simply work
in your garden when you want to
so the way that work is
um uh differ the way that work is
uh done is actually shaped by the
impulses
of wage work right so even though it is
not
but again because it's human concrete
labor
it constantly has these potentials
for disruption and you know obviously
wage labor does that too that's what a
strike is
but we should also think about the the
moments of disruption that can happen
here because capital doesn't have direct
control
to come to the more important question
is when um
have they ever struck work
simultaneously
um you know i i
let's remember that the two most
important
um revolutions of modern times
the the french and the russian 1789 and
1905 and 1917
both started off with bread writings
which was
you know women and and this is
acknowledged in
all of the contemporary writing that it
was
women breaking um through
you know baker's shops where bread was
being hoarded or
you know um losing shops and and
demanding bread for themselves and their
families
that actually sparked off the revolution
which set off then a series of wage
strikes right so
so so the question for us
as social justice activists should be
um to to consider
um not so much that these two spheres
are separate but to consider that
sometimes a resistance will spark in one
sphere
but can easily spread to the other right
that's very helpful while we're waiting
for
people to post some questions if they
have them maybe i'll follow up
i wonder if you could say this is more
of a technical issue
in the in the dialectic but i wonder if
you could say a little more about how
the domestic sphere
or the reproductive sphere is included
so for example i can see it as a point
of resist
possible point of resistance because
there's just other
values or purposes you call them
life-making
right and there's remnants of not just
remnants but
full-fledged endorsement of other
hermeneutic frameworks like
religious ones or whatever it be
outside of the workplace and even inside
of the workplace that go along alongside
it
so you could say well life making is a
separate value and it can
offer a point of resistance on
on its terms at times
but there's also a pressure from from
capital let's say
to to reduce
that life-making activity to the
absolute minimum
because it's even though it doesn't
contribute to value
or you could say it doesn't you can't
generalize it so you can't measure value
on diaper changes
that's a really useful way to to put it
um the worker has to
say cover in the value of their labor
not only herself
but her dependents so it's contributing
in some way to the value of labor like
the magnitude of the value of labor is
also how much this
heteronormative family requires to go on
right so if capital could get rid of it
i guess
it would no um
get rid of the family domestic sphere
reproductive labor as much as possible
i'm thinking of the other side
which is not resistance from
those other um positions but
the interest would be you know kind of
like um
yeah to get to get to get rid of it
so it doesn't seem to be possible but i
wonder if you see pressures from that
side also whatever that means automation
right um okay so um so to get rid of it
and because it wants more
um time in the wage sphere is is that
what you're
saying it would theoretically reduce the
value of labor
if labor didn't also have to provide for
the lives of its
of the laborers dependents right
sure yeah but that that's i mean let's
think about
um you know the historical examples here
that that's a really really um
great point actually paul and i'm
um very grateful for it because we
should have talked about it a little bit
like let's think about the historical
origins of capitalism
as as a historic system in in let's say
you know
northern england right so uh i mean this
is this is the uh where marx
in volume one talks so um
uh so laudably about the the the
factory inspectors right because what
capital was actually
doing was pulling all of the labor uh
into the factory and therefore thereby
completely undermining social
reproduction of the working class family
so people were just dying and i always
say when i teach
uh capital volume one is that the
companion piece
is not necessarily um uh
excuse me grindr said but the companion
piece
is actually engels's uh condition of the
working class in england right because
that
shows you in in very um descriptive ways
what happens if
uh social reproduction capital does not
kind of close its eyes to that loss of
profit
by maintaining the working-class family
what happens it it
undermines its very um possibility of
existence right because without the
working-class family without the
life-making there would be no workers
right so
it so this is in a way something that we
have to
actually think about really and this is
why i'm so grateful for the point you
bring up
we have to think about this very clearly
in terms
of the current ecological
emergency because accumulation is
actually pushing not so much in terms of
the early
in terms of the 18th century or early
19th century
um sort of the extinguishing of the
working-class family
but it is pushing again
to a point where it's undermining
even the possibility of value production
and accumulation
by pushing the planet at to the edge of
a climate catastrophe
which will undermine its own condition
of possibility right
so i think this is the dynamic that we
have to be attentive to constantly under
capitalism
that this what it can get away with
by not giving and what it
can what it is forced to give albeit
reluctantly
in order to ensure this continuous
reliable
production reproduction circuit
that's very helpful thank you and i love
the picture of capital
the capital system as being this kind of
anxious old person
worried about the incursions on all
sides
we have some questions and i want to
start with a question by elena gomez
if we can unmute elena and if you don't
mind asking
your question hi thank you so much
um i was just wondering if you could
talk
a little bit about how you see the kind
of
historicization of srt in relation to
marxist feminism
um particularly in the 1970s um
i'm interested in kind of whether you
see this as like a theoretical departure
or if it's an extension or if it's kind
of out of a different
tradition um and whether
srt was is able to ask questions that
were maybe
not available to the theorists such as
summer james
and leopoldina fortunately etc thanks
shall i just answer or wait for more
would you like to gather a few or do you
want to answer one by one
let me just let me just try to answer
this because um i think it's a very
important one so thank you for that
elena
um so
i think first of all uh we should start
any discussion about 1970s um
sort of marxist feminism by saying
that this version of srt
as we developed from capital volume one
in more recent times and and
you know just just to go back lisa vogel
who kind of pioneers some of this
thinking
lisa's book was actually published in
the early 80s so
you know even though it has had a sort
of
regeneration in recent times
and we can talk about why that
regeneration has happened because i have
some ideas about that
lisa's work actually isn't too
sort of modern you know marxism and the
oppression of women was first published
in 1983.
so um but it is
actually it it forms a departure from
the earlier marxist feminist
uh thinking on domestic labor okay
because srt as we talked about is is
we talk a lot about domestic labor but
it is very different kind of placing and
positioning and theorizing and exploring
of domestic labor very different from
um selma james and sylvia federici
and leopold fortunately
so um the first thing to say
is i think i owe a debt of gratitude
a big debt of gratitude to the
1970s domestic labor uh
debate okay and and the reason for that
is
remember domestic labor as a theoretical
category
uh lies you know the seeds of it lie in
capital volume one
the discussion of it happens in early
marxist and socialist thought you know
one can think about
alexandra colentai but it is
but it's it it's kind of that that that
that discussion is submerged and lost in
history
and it is these comrades and activists
and scholar activists of the 1970s
who resurrect this category
politicize it and theorize it okay so we
all actually well oh a real debt of
gratitude to
these uh to these thinkers and activists
and they don't just theorize it they
actually
go to battle on it right which is which
is most most important
so having said that i also have to say
as you might have guessed as as i
indicated
that i don't think i don't agree with
the way they theorize domestic labor
because
these theories argue that domestic labor
actually creates value
and um and and i don't think it does
um it is the precondition for value but
it doesn't actually create value
so so that's a that's a sort of major uh
difference we have in the way
it is theorized and and that's
you know and and it it because it's
theorized
slightly differently it often can have
different strategic um conclusions right
so if we can see
if we realize that uh domestic labor
can create value then we can think about
ways in which striking
or demanding wages for domestic labor is
actually going to disrupt
capital and you know we have to
and again if there is
you know uh if there is a strike
to stop domestic labor as the women's
strikes have shown
then that is actually a very powerful uh
means to do that but we also have to
think about the ways
in which wage labor has a conditioning
impulse
on domestic labor okay and so to
separate those two
uh in my mind is is not um is not going
to be helpful
but i want to end with saying
that if there is a barricade uh then
i think all of us are on the same side
of that barricade uh vis-a-vis how we
proceed in the family struggle
and i think these discussions and
debates and differences are actually
very productive and rich ways
of moving forward
there's a healthy role of questions in
the
in the chat so i'm gonna i'll read the
neck do you want to take them one by one
or do you prefer
grouping it's it's okay whichever thing
the next one i'm going to read out from
vanessa gubbins
following up on that one could you say
something more about the potential of
anti-capitalist
charge in life making activities in
relation to the difficulties that can
arise due to real subsumption
okay real subsumption
[Music]
in the could you explain
could you talk about it a little more
vanessa do you want to hop on and yeah
just just
tell me and how do how you relate
um sort of domestic labor or life making
up
activity to real subsumption what did
you mean by that
we're just unmuting and getting
ourselves
ready
say audrey can you unmute vanessa
can you hear me yes yes we have you now
hi sorry about that
thank you so much for such an incredible
um talk i
actually think you already answered my
question
when you were answering paul's earlier
so um
but but just to say i was just thinking
of
real subsumption as the way in which
uh the reproductive sphere the
life-making sphere is already determined
by what's happening in where
capital more directly has um
an effect and i was thinking about the
the later capital
chapters in in capital where you go from
formal subsumption
to real subsumption as one's um
capital has become a totalizing system
that affects absolutely everything
and everything is read through that lens
even life-making activities so i thought
that would
perhaps um you know it's it's what has
been read as someone
of a more pessimistic marks in some
regard
but i think i was just wondering if you
had any thoughts on how that
could affect the potential
the revolutionary potential of these
fears that are less directly
controlled by wage labor um
okay no that's a great question thank
you vanessa
um so i'm going to start i'm going to
try to answer that
with the lyrics of a union song
from the earlier part of the um
20th century uh and and the american
union movement
it's a song that i i find fascinating
because
there is a recognition in the early
union movement of the unity of these
fears that you're talking about right so
this song
goes and i will not um
subject you to my singing but um the
song goes
um it's a strike song and it's
supposedly from
from the workers um and it says um
my something like my children are seven
in numbers and
and something and and they're all
starving but the refrain
is uh striking
striking we're striking for pairs of
shoes
and then you know then there is another
description of you know all the things
that the family is deprived of
and then it says striking striking we're
striking for bottles of milk
okay so in other words there's a
recognition
in the actual struggle which is
your world of real subsumption right
where
everything is under the dominance of
capital but
the reason why you are engaged in wage
labor
is not for money but for what money can
buy right so that
so in other words the relationship
between
wage labor and and life
is constant and is actually
not ruptured in the consciousness of the
worker
where it gets ruptured is in later sort
of
um both you know the left movement as
well as the union movement where
we see that in the workplace
we are fighting for wages well actually
let's reverse that idea and say yes
we're fighting for
wages but we're actually fighting for an
enhancement of life
that's why we want higher wages right
because
we want more um
uh relaxation time we want better health
care we want better
food for our families so that
union song actually for me unites these
two spheres in a very
beautiful way because there is a
recognition in the early part of the
union movement in this country
that the two spheres are intimately
connected
and we are actually all fighting for
life-making activities and the expansion
of
life-making activities and in fact the
wage
is an unnatural shadow
that falls between our self
and our means of sustaining that self
okay
there should not be that unnatural
divide between
us and our means of subsistence but the
wage is an artificial barrier
between those two which is why uh
you know one of um
sort of the young um srt
theorists um aaron jaffe has written
recently written a
short essay where he talks about
um the the potential of these
life-making
explorations under uh the pandemic
where you know the pandemic has kind of
agitated the ubiquity and
the um essential nature of the wage
right that the that we constantly go to
work and we get the wage
and we come home with the disruption of
things under the uh
under the pandemic we can see almost
transparently
the unnaturalness of the wage right
because there's been so much uh
secession in the workplace
and in in the home we also see what is
actually essential work to keep the
world going and it's not stock brokers
and and bankers it is actually
life-making activities of teachers
nurses
and and uh people in the home care home
etc
so um i don't know if if this answers
your question but i don't think
it the the architecture of capital
volume one
actually never distracts from the fact
that under real subsumption
that there there is this sort of um
hegemonic
monolith that is capital that
extinguishes all possibility of workers
struggle
in fact what it reveals is this constant
dynamic
of workers trying to win back
life-making resources from capital
and capital constantly having to
negotiate
as to how much it can give and how much
it will give or is forced to give
thank you so much that was wonderful
i want to ask a very short follow-up to
that how can you tell in life-making
activities
which ones are for life and which ones
are for capital
when they're
that's a really really interesting
question so
so this is i think connected to your
earlier question poll
that um while we think about
and concrete labor
and concretely laboring bodies we can
never forget
that we live under the shadow
of a systemic reproduction
of abstract labor right so um
so while you know
uh kissing your love loved one
is a life-making activity you can often
um you know finding time to do so
is part of uh what makes
uh it difficult sometimes right so but
what can you tell but um what is
life-making activity i i think
uh there are the the problem
the the the fact that you can even ask
that question
should alert us to the fact that
through historically life-making
activities are
continuously commodified right
so um uh just like
domestic labor is actually commodified
you know if you have enough money as a
woman
you can get away with not doing a job of
domestic labor and actually um farming
it out to
immigrant uh women of color who come and
sweep and dust and clean and do whatever
it is
uh in your home and you wouldn't have to
do a bit of work
right so so capital will
constantly as we know will try to
commodify and
every element even in the sphere of
life making right however
this does not finally
i want to constantly go back to the idea
that that does not mean that it always
succeeds
that that charge and that dynamic of
concrete labor continuously remains
and actually has to remain if
capital has to um you know
um has to survive so
uh women or female marked bodies
have to give birth you know sometimes
they'll give
birth under uh certain kinds of
historical conditions
and other times under others but you
know
those sort of processes have to
continuously take place
and it actually isn't capitalists worth
to actually you know factory farm an
entire
uh generation of workers right it just
isn't
the kind of investment it has to make in
order to do that
uh in in changing social moore's in
creating such factory farms it just
isn't worth it i mean it gets this work
done
uh very cheaply free of cost in most
working-class households why should it
invest
in in you know that kind of a
fully auto well again
you cannot fully um automatize care
i mean this is this is the big thing
right so they they
try to mechanically reproduce
care especially in the privatized
medical industry and we
see the problems with that right so
when you say that the that there are
little beepers that the nurse will
only stay by your bedside uh for
five minutes and you know and has to
take take on the uh on the chart and
each the nurse has to complete you know
x number of bed visits per day
uh it just doesn't work you know uh
in the sense that care cannot be um
you know mechanized in that that that
extent and that's that's a problem that
that capital has as it were
so i'm going to tell my partner that
she's not kissing me just to make sure
i'm home at the end of the day to make
dinner
i want to turn now this is a good moment
to i think turn to gabrielle
wynan's question i don't know gabrielle
i think just
maybe left the room but if gabrielle is
here
this was a question about the
commodification of of reproductive
labor can we open up gabrielle's
voice
okay gabriel is here but on the phone
but we should still be able to unmute
would you like gabrielle would you like
me to read the question
okay this is the most bizarre way to
communicate with anyone
thanks for a great talk gabrielle says
it strikes me you mainly consider srt in
relation to its input to the value of
labor power
as itself an uncommodified form of labor
i'm curious what you make of the growing
commodification of reproductive labor
which we just began to talk about
which often occurs through the social
state in partial or limited commodified
forms
what is the significance of the
absorption of so much of this labor into
the labor market in the last 50 years
and what should we make of the
historical limits to capital that have
arisen
in its employment
um
so um you know
um i think by historical limits i think
um that's that's what we talked about
that you can't mechanize
care completely okay so you can
commodify
um domestic labor and the reproduction
of life to a certain extent
but you cannot mechanize or commodify it
entirely
and uh so that's that would be my first
kind of response to you um
the the other side of it is
that when you i mean um my
um friend and colleague in umass amherst
um
nancy fulbert who's a feminist economist
she talks about for instance um
one of the problems of workers in the
care industry
striking right so she calls it the the
love problem okay so what's the love
problem
that often especially for home
house home health um
care workers right those who come into
the home to care for the elderly etc
who by the way did the majority of the
caring for
um our elders during this pandemic and
are were primarily women of color right
and so
um we're absolutely at the at the
sort of the full blast of the of the
disease
of the virus so um what happens with
home health care workers
um you know because care
is such a
sort of human i want to say human
and indeed anti-capitalist impulse right
care and love are human and
anti-capitalist impulses that we carry
as a species
so even when you commodify it it
actually ha creates certain um
problems right so for instance with a
home health care worker
she gets so involved in the care
of her patient of her client the person
she's
providing uh care for that
when when it comes to striking
she feels well i can't strike because
this will
leave this really vulnerable person
high and dry and and this actually will
affect their life chances
so how can i strike right so this is
something
that um care workers face all the time
in in terms of striking you know
that whenever um as we all know there
was a
wave wonderful wave of teacher strike
in this country uh two years ago in 2017
uh you know the first thing was oh how
could you be so selfish and strike
because this affects the lives and
futures of our children
okay so when nurses go on strike how can
you possibly strike
because you are endangering the health
the very life
you know the messy fleshy life of
of human beings right so care work
at this this kind of so in other words
it is not just care workers commodified
but the
impulse to care is often weaponized by
capital to actually stop care workers
from striking right so that very impulse
that makes us human
capital weaponizes against us so you
can't strike because you ought to care
um i think my answer to that
i learned actually from concrete worker
struggles
so workers then
had to devise a way to actually
frame their struggle which shows
that they're striking because they care
so it is because they care
for the future lives of their students
of their patients
so that they make care properly and
sustainably
that they are striking so in other words
you know in all of these care work
strikes that you
um if you follow as i do
you will see that workers reframe their
struggle
into actually talking about the depths
of care that they have
for their patients and for their
students
and which is why they're forced to
strike right so
um so i remember 2012
the chicago teachers union when they
went for strike that was like
you know the first teacher strike in so
many so many years of recent memory and
it was such a great strike
and remember that for the chicago
teachers
eighty percent of their students are
students of color okay
and uh you know uh the the mayor of
chicago at the time
closed schools mostly on the south side
of chicago
where you know the all the black
children and and latino children went to
school right
so when the but the framing i thought of
this chicago teachers strike
was so wonderful said that our working
conditions
are our students learning conditions
right so in other words
unless our working conditions improve
we are not able to love and care for our
students in the way our students deserve
right so it was a very interesting
to me learning process for us to see how
workers in struggle just as marx
predicted
actually can reframe the struggle for
care
into talking about real substantive care
rather than the weaponized care that
capital forces upon them
it makes me think of a beautiful thing
that tends to happen in
strikes and in group actions that
there's a kind of care that arises among
the strikers
that's really very different than
anything we're talking about kind of
the ideal okay we have a set of
questions and i'm
mindful of your um labor power
no that's fine that's fine we'll go a
little longer
you okay okay
yeah that's a great question because you
know when we say
um we want more public service right
we want um more um
state intervention um
in in the market so we want these
services taken off the market
taken off private uh privatized
sphere and into public control right
so that sounds like a great demand that
we're saying
that it should healthcare should be
public or
education should be public we should
have public laundries and so on
but we are also saying at the same time
if we
go via foucault we're also saying that
then that means that the capitalist
state
is actually in charge of this right so
which is
ought to be a scary prospect right so
um so we are saying um healthcare
uh education should be public but the
word public
actually um hides in a way the
idea that what we mean by public is also
the capitalist state because we are
asking for state control as it were
right
so um so i think that's a very
interesting and important um uh
issue that we ought to be discussing uh
what are the lim
and this is where i think um marx's
state theory
is something that we have to um
this should be like the sort of next
chapter of
social reproduction theory like how does
social reproduction theory engage with
marx's
state theory right because uh i think it
has to in
in in a way because the state is both
the repository
of the disciplining functions of capital
as well as
the public functions of the reproduction
of
life right so so for instance
um you know when um
this early uh like look you know i i
don't know if you're in
paul's class um but uh emerson
but you know uh in in capital volume one
marx uh as i said uh you know is is
absolutely um
full of praise for the government
inspectors who come into
the the factories and inspect those
conditions you know he goes through all
these blue books of the
um inspectors and and when he writes his
uh
especially his chapter on the working
day and
and that is where we are talking about
that the even in the sphere of
production
in the point of production question that
their their
marx is uh welcoming
state oversight over
simple operation of private capital
right that
it's only the capitalist state that
steps in to actually
regulate how uh wages are determined on
the factory floor
and the fact that capital is actually
undermining its own condition of
possibilities so it's
the capitalist state steps in and says
okay you need to stop and we need to
reconfigure the whole thing here and and
so labor laws are passed and
and so on hours of work but
it is the same today right so we are
asking for uh uh
the the government to step in to
regulate health care or
education as it does in several you know
nordic countries
but we cannot forget that it is the
capitalist state
right so it's not the um you know sort
of
we are not talking about workers control
over the process of production so the
capitalist state
will have a you know will
impose the law of capital
or will impose the law of value to a
certain extent and we cannot expect
otherwise from it this is where i think
um social democratic governments uh
will join the first world war you know
1914 right and and shock
lenin and luxembourg into it this is why
social democratic governments today are
often
virulent practicers of virtual
that they want strong borders against
migrants because they want to control
the the weight the distribution of the
wage within their own national economies
right
so on the one hand and this is why
this contradiction of the capitalist
state
providing life-making activities
on the one hand we celebrate we
absolutely want
free health care free um
free free education uh from our taxes
right
but we cannot forget that the state
ultimately will also impose the law of
value
okay because it is the capitalist state
it's not an orchestration so
so for instance what we see is this
dark development in recent times
that in the nordic countries there is
uh this argument that
yes we have health care but it is only
for
swedish workers so all these immigrants
need to be driven
yes we have good free education
but it is for our lovely white children
and not these muslims you know i was
shocked when i
went to copenhagen last year it seems
like a
million years ago that we used to travel
so and
and and and the papers where the
left-wing papers
were filled with stories of how um
uh muslims were actually muslim
immigrants had to live in ghettos and
had to follow an entirely different
program of sending their children to
school and
at daycare from the you know the good
white citizens
who were full citizens in in in the
country right
so we can see that even the
um the the generalized
reproduction of life-making activities
which we support
under the eegs of the capitalist state
can have its own
limits because it is the capitalist
state and not
you know a worker's controlled
cooperative or what have you
right so basically the kind of principal
differences
between like the good and bad demands
are mostly in terms of like
the status of the state of like racism
and uh democratic versus authoritarian
tendencies
so like we can see social reproductive
demands in the
service of like straws right nazism or
whatever
so it's like those are the kinds of ways
we should distinguish them in
i'm not sure i understood
just that my original question was like
the principal demands between the social
reproduction
demands which are disruptive versus
non-disruptive have to take in all those
other
contexts basically of course yes right
yeah thank you okay wanna
if you still have the energy give the
floor to paul ryder to ask
a final question of course oh goodness
that's a lot of pressure um after such a
thing
such a such an incredible talk and uh
and a wonderful discussion as well
um thanks so much um i uh
i have a question um
a couple of questions but i'll i'll
limit myself since the hour is so
advanced and
and uh just ask this one you started out
talking about or positioning your
your argument in response to one that
suggests that the book is really
very much focused on abstract labor and
that's ultimately what's at stake here
and i thought you did a really wonderful
job of
of debunking that in a in a in a
theoretical way um and i wonder
if there's also a more
since so much of it this is about the
relation between the theoretical and the
empirical or historical and
capital if there's an empirical way to
uh to push back against that
as as well because it seems to me that
um
outside of the working day chapter
they're just so many places in capital
um where marx points out
the tendency of the system to
exploit a particularly vulnerable
population
and and use that um to uh
to make conditions generally worse or
gain a kind of general
advantage um and so that uh even if he
doesn't
frame this point as a kind of of uh
in part of this theoretical argument it
emerges
as uh as part of the argument that he's
making that there's a tendency in this
system
um systematically to go after vulnerable
populations so that if there's any
inequality at all among the the workers
that inequality will be exploited and
since it's very hard to imagine
that there could ever be any
uh total lack of of inequality
among the working population under
capitalism and its various pressures
that it's uh it's therefore
uh seem that it therefore seems very
unlikely that this book would be
suggesting
that these inequalities are the
inequalities other than class
inequalities are somehow incidental
to capitalist exploitation that there's
a
there's an accumulation of evidence that
you could present in other words
in response to this in addition to the
theoretical argument that you're making
oh i completely agree and i think you
know when when i say
that um
srt um takes
issues with certain formulations in the
way labor power
is presented in capital i mean i
always couch that in in
say in in the general framework that
srt only exists as a theory using
capital volume one as its architecture
right because it is
from the from the understanding of
how labor power is crucial to the
functioning
of capital and how that has a
uh and how that creates the conditions
of possibility
of the system as a whole that the
starting point of that
is uh capital volume one and there are
several
several passages in the text itself
that point us back constantly to this
reproduction of labor power and its
various modalities
what capital volume 1 doesn't do but
what
what marx himself does in in other texts
is talk about the gendered and
racialized uh
nature of the reproduction of labor
power and and the effect it has
right but um i completely agree with you
that the text is actually
peppered it's it's studded with uh
various
um issues about the
the uh potential of um
concrete labor of um of the
potential of uh the the spaces
of the reproduction of labor power
becoming the sort of anti-capitalist
um resistance to uh wage labor
so i i mean you know you never get the
impression
through the reading of the text that um
abstract the dominance of abstract labor
is complete or even
um absolute in in
it it is it is that way in the
form in which the system operates but
you get this
constant understanding of the dynamic
the pushbacks
uh to it throughout throughout the text
so actually
well there is frequently this message
that in in some ways
uh things getting worse is progress
because
it it galvanizes workers resistance
and it uh ripens the conditions
under which some sort of meaningful
change will occur right i mean in the
working day chapter there's so much back
and forth where he
uh points out that the the
laws that regulate factory labor that
yes you know this is a positive thing on
the other hand
they've had these negative unintended
consequences of
intensifying um capitalist production in
some ways making it even more ferocious
because it has to operate within a
limited
more limited time framework but at the
same time then that
um very what you could see as a setback
has the effect in his estimation of
bringing about conditions that will
hasten
the advance of the workers movement and
so ultimately that you know
could be a good thing um i mean that
this is obviously a you know a
discussion that that
could go on um because you're at the
point of
and this is one of the of course one of
the challenges of the book that it is
so big and diverse and
um there are uh
uh moments where or or there is uh
some amount of variation among the
different parts and
contradictory statements or at least
contrasting statements and
what reading you'll come up with can
depend on which parts you choose to
emphasize these parts where marx seems
more optimistic or parts
where there's a certain mood of
pessimism
that that that sets in and
to make your arguments stick if you're
going to argue in this way you know then
you have to
really catalog exhaustively and and show
at the end of the day that you have a
lot of evidence and
and support for what you're you know
what you're saying and i
um i mean i do think that there's a lot
of evidence just to support
what you were just saying and uh in any
case
um i uh i'm i feel like i'm now going
from the question
uh mode to the comment mode and i don't
want to do that because this is you know
your presentation so
let me pull back and give you a last
word
oh that was excellent thank you no no no
i i wish we had more time i always think
you know even after two hours of
everyone to
all this talking so i i i want
obviously this is this is the starting
point i hope of more discussions on
on this subject i just want to frame um
sort of um use what you said as a point
of departure
um about the sort of intensification of
accumulation
urging workers um to you know higher
levels of struggle
i just want to use that as a point of
departure to say but in our current
times
i think we have to frame that somewhat
in the context of the ecological crisis
right
so um we can think about
um you know uh expanded uh reproduction
and extensive
uh drive for accumulation urging workers
struggle but it may all be too late
in the sense that you know the planet
may have moved
or may move may have moved beyond
a tipping point where uh such struggles
will
ultimately not yield the results
that we we want that we may not be able
to move
to a an alternative system of capitalism
and i think
here i find walter benjamin
uh quite useful in thinking about our
current moment
um in in in terms of uh you know the
the the planetary crisis uh
looming over us that we think about
workers struggles
more as a break upon
this hurtling train of accumulation
um more as a break than as necessarily
anything else that we have to first stop
you know the the current sort of
constant drive
we have to think about worker struggles
uh because
otherwise the train is gonna and
unfortunately we are all on the train
not just
capitalists and the train is gonna
hurtle beyond
everybody's control and and to the
common rune of contending classes as as
the famous code goes but i don't want to
end on that extremely dark note i want
to end on the note that
that kind of possibility of the common
rune of
contending classes is constantly being
challenged
by a new generation of uprising as we
saw
in over the summer the the most fierce
and the most wonderful multi-racial
uprising that we saw that challenged the
very uh
processes of um differential life making
and the the children's strikes that we
saw last year
against ecological devastation so i want
to
end on that note and look towards those
kind of
horizons as our possibilities for the
future
and we thank you for that and for the
talk a great round of applause
thank you so much would be happening
thanks again for coming